We've got good news.
We've got this focus, Speaker McCarthy.
And we've reached
the bipartisan budget agreement
that we're ready to move
to the full Congress
and I think is a really important
step forward. Excuse me.
And it takes
the threat of catastrophic
to fall off the table.
Protects our hard
earned and historic economic recovery.
And the agreement
also represents a compromise,
which means no one got
everything they want.
But that's the responsibility
of governing.
And now this deal is good news for
I believe you'll see
for the American people,
the agreement prevents
the worst possible crisis.
And default
for the first time
in our nation's history.
An economic recession.
Retirement accounts devastated.
Millions of jobs lost.
It also protects key priorities
and accomplishments and values
that congressional Democrats
and I have fought long
for long
and hard
for investing in America's agenda.
That's creating good jobs and communities
throughout the country.
Protect Social Security,
Medicare and veterans, and so much more.
The speaker and I made it
clear from the start
that the only way forward
was a bipartisan agreement.
That agreement now
goes to the United States House
and to the Senate.
I strongly urge both
both chambers to pass that agreement.
Let's keep moving forward
on meeting our obligations
and building the strongest economy
in the history of the world.
I'll take a few questions.
President,
you said at the beginning
that the deficit is not negotiable.
Isn't that what you've just done here?
Isn't that what you guys can't negotiate?
Here's the deal.
They passed they said they're going to
they pass the debt ceiling
and they said
they would only do it on condition
that it have all these cuts in it.
I said, I'm not going to do that.
You pass the debt ceiling period.
I'll negotiate with you on the cuts,
what you say.
What's going to happen with the budget's
going to look like
that's what we are to go know
in order
to get to
them deciding
that they're going to
go along with a new debt ceiling meeting
that is not attached to something
totally different attached.
It was attached before.
Suppose you want to try to make it
look like I made some compromise
on the debt ceiling and I didn't.
I made a compromise on the budget.
That's what they wanted
is you make a compromise on the budget
and that's what you've got,
even though you haven't gone
as far as they wanted.
Isn't that sure? Yeah.
Well, I can think of an alternative
but the president.
What do you say to
members of your own party
who say you need
to make concessions in this deal?
Well, find I didn't
Mr.
President, on your
on your allies and adversaries
to America,
would you be willing to say
about what you think
this process said
to those adversaries and allies?
We have a deal now,
but what does the process say?
What does the struggle process?
We've been through this more than once,
and it's just the nature of the way
we handle the deficit and handle
whether we're going to each year going to
pay our debts.
And it's happened
more than once
will probably happen again.
But it's not going to happen
at least for another two years here.
And I don't think beyond
I think beyond that it won't either.
Do you think it's time for the U.S.
to get rid of the debt limit
that this is, you know,
for that
for the reasons you just laid out?
No, I think you would
cause more controversy
getting rid of the debt limit,
although I do.
I am exploring the idea that we would
at a later date,
the year or two from now, decide
whether or not
the 14th Amendment,
how that actually would impact
on whether or not you need to do
the debt limit every year.
But that's another day Mr.
President, do you believe
Speaker McCarthy has the votes
and did he negotiate in good faith?
I think he negotiated with me in
good faith.
He kept his word.
He said what he would do.
He did do what he said he'd do.
And I have no idea at that.
I expect he does,
but I don't think
he would have made the agreement.
Mr.
President, do you have a
do you have any
comment on the elections in Turkey?
Have you spoken with President Erdogan?
I have not spoken to him yet.
Do you wish you had a common money
hard saying
that his
policy will lead
some people to go hungry?
What is your response to that
ridiculous assertion?
Do you wish
you started getting a petition sooner?
No. The main difference, Mr.
President, is
financial aid for Ukraine secured in
your new budget.
Okay.
There you have
President Biden speaking to reporters
just a few moments ago.
He was saying essentially there
that he believes
that the House speaker, Kevin
McCarthy,
was negotiating
in good faith during this process.
At one point,
I think you were sparring
with Peter Baker
of The New York Times
a bit there and said, well,
what's the alternative
when it comes to negotiating or not
negotiating over the debt ceiling?
Let me go to you,
Congresswoman Debbie Wasserman Schultz.
And I interrupted you,
although I did warn you in advance
that that might happen.
Your response
to what the president had exactly.
to what the president had to say there,
because he was reminded
of the fact that he did say
he didn't want to negotiate
over the debt ceiling
and then he had a negotiator
over the debt ceiling.
That's when he said, well,
what's the alternative there?
It sounds as though
the president,
the White House Democrats really just
didn't have a choice here.
You had to negotiate over
the debt ceiling
Well, you know,
I was pleased that
right from the beginning
of the discussions they took,
whether or not
we were going to raise the debt
ceiling and crash
our economy off the table.
Both sides agreed
we're not going to do that.
And then I mean, Jim,
you know, as a longtime
member of the Appropriations Committee,
I can tell you
this is the time of year
when we are negotiating
the appropriations top lines anyway.
Essentially,
we did that,
you know, more
at the beginning of the process
through these negotiations.
And that's what we talked
about on our caucus.
This now
We probably would have not wanted to get
as much
in the weeds in terms of the framework
at this point in the game.
But we had a lot at stake
and it's really critical.
We had Republicans
who were willing to crash our economy
into the side of a cliff,
who were willing to not pay our bills,
by the way, on a deficit
that they ran up themselves.
They have a $1.3 trillion unpaid
bill of tax cuts
that they wouldn't touch,
mostly that went to millionaires
and wealthy people.
And that was off limits
in those discussions,
which is outrageous.
I mean,
when you have tax cuts,
you're pulling revenue out of
the economy. And
that counts just as much as spending.
And the Republicans under Donald Trump
didn't pay for any of that.
So they took that off the table.
We were operating in a situation
where we had to protect veterans funding
if they were willing to cut.
We had to make sure
that we were going to have
the kind of funding needs
that were not supposed
draconian
from the cuts that they proposed.
We ended up at FY 23 levels.
The Republicans are trying to spin it.
Is that by 22?
But I know the details
and I know the granularity of it
at the end of the day
when we go through the appropriations
process will be at 23 levels.
And by the way, we're protecting
and ensuring
that we don't go through this again
and next year.
A quick, quick
follow up on on
what the President had to say.
Congresswoman, right there
at the very end he indicated that
maybe not before the 20, 24 election,
maybe it's after the 20, 24 election.
It sounds like he's
going to be revisiting the idea
of the 14th Amendment
and whether or not
the President
can essentially raise the debt ceiling
himself or herself
by virtue of the 14th Amendment.
Did you pick up on that
when he said that?
And what are your thoughts?
Is it
time for the United States
to have a system
where you don't have to go
through the Congress
to raise the debt ceiling?
It sounds like the president said
that would be too disruptive right now,
but it sounds like
he is receptive to that idea perhaps
down the road.
What did you make of that?
Well, I personally have always thought
we should take off the table
whether or not
we pay our bills,
that our nation,
our debts, that our nation is a.
There's no family in America
that has the ability
to not pay their bills.
They can't just decide not to do that,
and neither can we.
And that shouldn't be subject
to the political whims
or the hostage taking ability of one side
or the other.
In this case,
the Republicans are always
the ones that are repeatedly
willing to do that
and hold the gun to the nation's
the head of the nation's economy.
I do think we should take
that off the table,
although I've heard the president
say that it wouldn't be responsible,
and I thought he meant
it wouldn't be responsible
to eliminate the debt ceiling.
So I'm not really clear.
I wasn't quite clear
what he was saying, but
I know he wasn't wanting to
go through
the 14th Amendment
with the potential
for judicial challenges now.
And perhaps he would revisit
that down the road.
But at the end of the day,
we have to pay our bills.
We shouldn't be going,
yeah, we can't have a default.
That would be catastrophic.
And even we can.
Let me since
you're right here in the studio with me,
your thoughts on
what the president had had to say.
What stood out to you?
He said that he believes the House
speaker, Kevin McCarthy,
is negotiating in good faith.
That may not sit
well with a lot of
McCarthy's Republican, very conservative
Republican colleagues
who wish
that McCarthy had gotten
more out of this.
But this is always
who President Biden has been.
He is always a creature of the Senate.
He's always been this pragmatic lawmaker
moderate,
willing to work with Republicans.
You know, when I saw him
come out,
I thought
this makes it all the more hard
for Republicans to argue
that he is beholden to the left.
Clearly, he is not
if he is willing to make
these compromises.
But it was a reversal, to be clear, Jim,
he said all along
I have argued that the only way
forward is a bipartisan agreement.
He has not said that all along.
That is incorrect.
He initially said that
that this was non-negotiable.
Well, he negotiated
and he yeah, he long said there would be
should be no compromise
when it comes to the debt ceiling,
that this is obligatory,
that this is the responsibility
of Congress
So ultimately, he did have to compromise.
But I don't know
how much of a political liability
it is for him
because it robs Republicans
of a talking point
that he is totally dictated
by progressives in the left flank.